- [Narrator] Welcome back
to Upper Peninsula State
closed-circuit TV.
From time to time we
wire guys on the court,
refs on the court,
just to hear what's going
on behind the scenes.
Check it out.
- [Jeff] Hey, how are you?
- [Rodney] How's it going man?
Nice to meet you.
- I'm Jeff.
- Yeah, Rondy man, Rodney man.
- Just washed my hands.
Was just in the bathroom.
- [Narrator] This is
gonna be fun tonight.
- All right.
- All right, get ready.
- All right ladies.
Shake 'em.
Don't bake 'em.
- I usually do the tip-off.
- I wanna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
- Okay.
(whistle)
- All right, here we go.
Here we go.
(whistle)
- Time-Out.
- We've got a little
time to kill, probably.
Do you play?
- Oh, do I play?
- A little crossover.
- Nah, nah.
- (Whistle) Time-Out over.
- Charging.
- Charging?
- Charging. I planted my foot.
(whistle) It's a charge.
- Nah, that's a block.
- That's a charge.
- No, that's a block.
- That's what a charge is.
- Hey man, that's a charge.
- No, that's a block.
- Hey. What? That's a charge.
- Do what you did.
Do what you did.
- No, she--
- You see that?
- But that's not what happened.
- [Jeff] What's the story
with the on-campus restaurant?
Is it a list situation?
They take money?
Is it points?
Can you use points?
- [Rodney] Some
people get in here,
they see a bunch of
tall, beautiful women.
No offense, but it's the truth.
- (whistle) Foul!
- Oh, okay, okay.
I got it, I got it.
I got it, I got it,
No, stay down.
- You're all right.
She's all right.
Get up. You can get up.
She can get up.
- I got it.
Stay down.
- She wants to get
up? Let her get up.
- Let's get some ice.
Let's get some ice for her!
- You see, you're problem is
you're coming in way too hot.
They don't like that.
You gotta come in subtle.
- What are you talking about?
Are you talking about
hooking up with girls?
- Hey man.
Hey you said it.
I didn't.
You pick one girl, and you
give her the attention.
- That's the way.
You know who I like?
- Which one?
- 15.
- 15, That's your girl?
I see.
I knew you were a dirty dog.
I knew you were gonna
like one of them.
- Nah, come on, man.
- 15? I thought
that was your girl.
Hey, hey.
Foul on 15.
- What are you doing, man?
- Save her.
Save her.
Come on.
- No way that's a foul on 15.
No, no, take that back.
- Hey man--
- Take that back.
- I said it's a foul.
You sure?
- Yeah, I'm sure.
- All right, man.
Whatever you say.
- Okay, that's not a foul on 15.
You're still in the
game sweetheart.
- Trust me.
Trust me.
That's gonna pay off.
In dividends.
(refs laughing)
- I'd give him a shot.
I'd give him a shot.
That's all I'm saying.
Did what I could.
- What's your favorite
M. Night Shyamalan movie?
- Signs, no question.
- Yeah.
- Looks like he's got a
yellow glooey on his head.
(refs laughing)
- Cause I was thinking
that for a while now.
- As I said, I call
it like I see it.
Hey dooty head,
get off the court.
(refs laughing)
All right.
(buzzer buzzing)
That's the game.
That's it.
- [Narrator] Sometimes,
what you hear on the court
can be surprisingly uplifting.
That's it for today.
Remember it's amnesty
week at the library,
so get those books back there.
- [Rodney] When I whip out
Eye of the Tiger by Survivor.
- [Jeff] Not if I
get there first.